[MUSIC PLAYING]
SAMIR FALKE: Have you ever
designed and developed products
for users who are very
different from you?
Well, today, we are going to go
over some tips and strategies
to deeply understand
your user and to create
effective products for them at
speed, using immersive design
sprints.
I'm Samir Falke.
I'm a design lead
at Google Station.
And Google station
is a product that's
building high quality
public Wi-Fi for users
in next billion user markets.
BURGAN SHEALY: And I'm Burgan.
I'm a designer on
the Chrome team,
focusing on our
next billion users.
All right, let's jump
right in and talk about--
there we go.
What is a design sprint?
So we'll do a brief
recap of design sprints.
So we define a design
sprint as a framework
for answering critical business
questions through design,
prototyping, and testing
our ideas with users
to generate actionable
feedback and insights.
Now, design sprints
were created at Google,
and they have evolved over time.
They're a mix of methods from
design thinking, business
strategy, psychology,
and user research,
that were all selected
and ordered specifically
to support divergent
and convergent thinking,
and to drive towards
a targeted outcome.
So what's different
about a design sprint
is that we set clear goals
and deliverables upfront.
We time box all
of the activities
so that we not only speed up
the learning and development
process, but we also drive the
right behaviors from our users.
And then finally, we enable
a wide range of disciplines
and stakeholders to participate
in the design and development
process.
Now, design is not
an individual sport.
And design sprints are a
highly collaborative process.
We want to be able to
include multiple perspectives
and points of views.
And to that end,
we leverage sprints
to include all
participant's voices.
The design is a highly
flexible framework,
and you'll want to
flex it and adapt it
to your particular
challenge or scenario.
One of the advantages
of the sprint
is you can reduce the risks
of downstream mistakes
by getting to insights
that lead to a better
understanding of your user and
your problem space quicker.
So today, we're going
to talk about a way
that we have flexed the design
sprint to really get a better
understanding of users that are
very different from ourselves.
Through immersion,
intercepts, and co-creation,
we're bringing actual users
instead of representatives
of those users into the center
of the design and development
process.
Now, there's a phenomenon known
as the co-creation effect.
And it shows that when
organizations and consumers
create something
together, both parties are
more invested in the outcome.
So what does this
look like in practice?
We're going to start by
bringing a team together
of very different disciplines,
including UX, Eng, PM,
to create a powerful team.
We're looking for a
good representation
of roles and skills.
And this is going to allow
us to dramatically reduce
the amount of time that
we spend communicating
and increase the number of
viable ideas that we generate.
So once we have
our team together,
we're going to walk through
the five sprint phases,
understand, sketch, decide,
prototype, and validate.
Now, we have a mix of
structured individual work
and planned group
discussions that
support a clear
diverge and converge
process that will
guide the team to get
on the same page
around the artifacts
that it's going to produce
to test with the users.
Now, the ideal design
sprint is going
to provide time for
team members to reflect
on the challenge, and also,
opportunities to validate
or disrupt those ideas.
So the goal for the first
phase, the understand phase,
is to gather all of the relevant
data and information at hand.
We really want to
create a shared
brain and a line around
a new world together,
and a new understanding
of the problem space.
Then, we're going to move
on to the sketch phase.
And this is when we're
going to generate
tons and tons of ideas,
tons of potential solutions.
And we're going to use
a couple of exercises
that are designed to get the
ideas out of your participant's
head onto paper, and
to really push them
to go beyond their first idea to
get better and more innovative
ideas.
Now, once we have
all of these ideas
and we're in the
middle of a sprint,
we have tons and tons
of solutions, it's time
to start narrowing down
and making hard choices.
So the decide phase is all
about those hard decisions
and selecting what you're
going to prototype with users.
Once you've narrowed
down, you want
to create a prototype that
you can test your hypothesis
and validate or invalidate
your assumptions.
Because you only have a
really short amount of time,
maybe you have a
couple hours, maybe you
have a day to build
that prototype,
it should only be
as high fidelity as
needed to answer your
questions, and nothing more.
Finally, we're
going to validate.
The goal of the test
phase is to confirm
that the product that
you have prototyped
is good, and also, that you
prototyped the right thing.
So today, we're going to discuss
two case studies to show you
how we've used this framework
to give users the tool
to engage in the ideation
and creation process.
And now that you understand
the structure of a sprint,
when's the right time to sprint?
Really, you can sprint at
any point in the lifecycle
of your product.
You might be at
the very beginning
and want to use the sprint
for visioning or creating
a roadmap.
You may have a mature
product, and you're
thinking about adding
a specific feature.
Whatever point in the
life cycle of your product
that you run a sprint,
it's important to remember
that involving users
early and often
can really help validate
the problem space
and create better ideas.
And there are a couple of
outcomes from a sprint.
So I like to say
that there's never
a failed sprint because
you always learn something.
But we have to find
three potential outcomes.
And the first is an
efficient failure.
So it can be a
little dispiriting
that something didn't work,
but it's really useful to know.
And you've saved all of that
time, money, and resources
that you might have spent
building out the product
and then learning
that it didn't work.
So you learned quickly.
Now, most sprints fit
in this middle bucket,
what we called flawed success.
Some things worked,
some things didn't.
But you have a path forward.
You know what you
need to do next.
And sometimes you
have an epic win.
Maybe you have a couple
things you want to tweak,
but you're ready to
move to production.
You'll need to set
your expectations
with its stakeholders at
the beginning of the sprint
so that everyone
is aware of this,
and they know what
the outcomes might be.
Now, let's talk a little
bit about immersion.
SAMIR FALKE: Great.
So really comprehensive recap
of a very complex topic there.
And the reason that
we rushed through that
is because we are assuming
that if you're here, then
you've heard of a
design sprint before.
You have most likely taken
part in a design sprint before,
and maybe some of you have even
run your own design sprints.
So we are going to jump
right into immersion.
Now, before we talk
about immersive sprints,
let's try to understand what
immersion actually means.
So to think about
immersion, I went to Google
and I looked up the dictionary.
And here's a definition
of the term immersion.
Immersion is instruction
based on extensive exposure
to surroundings or conditions
that are native or pertinent
to the object of study.
Now, this is a lot to take in.
So I kept googling.
Here's another
definition, much simpler.
Immersion is a deep
mental involvement.
Here's a third one.
Immersion is the state of being
deeply engaged or involved.
Absorption.
All right, so there are
some common themes emerging
from all of these definitions.
Let's bring this back to UX.
How can immersion
guide your interaction
with users, especially users
that you don't know very well?
I like to think of it
in terms of three steps.
Step one.
Immersion is about awareness.
So first, doing the
background research and study
that it actually
takes before you
go into a new
environment and users.
Then, bringing those learnings
with you into these new
surroundings so that
they can provide you
the context that you need
to process that correctly.
And then when you're in
this new environment,
just being very keenly aware.
Observing without preconceived
notions, or bias, or judgment.
So that's awareness.
Step two.
Immersion is about listening.
So you're going to hear a lot
of new sounds, process a lot
of new sights.
You're going to talk
to a lot of users
that you haven't
interacted with before.
And these users are going to
tell you about their lives,
about their problems, problems
that you haven't faced before.
So it's really important
to listen attentively.
And this is actually
pretty hard to do.
If you tried
yourself, right now,
when you try to listen
to someone speaking,
it's very easy to let your mind
wander and think about what
you want to say next.
It's very hard to
mindfully listen.
I hope that's not
what you all are
doing right now, by the way.
But it's really important
to listen attentively.
So that's step two.
And then step three
is taking awareness,
and taking listening, and
bringing it to empathy.
And this is when
you are actually
stepping into someone's
shoes and experiencing
what they experience.
Understanding their
needs, their pain points,
their hopes and dreams, and
even things that delight them.
So when you have awareness,
listening, empathy,
all of these three
things together,
that's going to be
considered immersion.
So how does this relate to
design sprints and design?
Now, when you're in a design
sprint, you are making a call,
and you are designing
solutions for users
based on what you think is
going to work well for them.
Now, where does this come from?
It comes from intuition.
And how does
intuition get built?
It comes from a
lifetime of experience.
It comes from
knowledge and study.
It comes from trial and
error, like launching
a lot of designs, and
seeing what works,
and learning from success,
learning from failure.
It's a constant loop of
learning and tweaking.
But when you're
designing for users
that you've never
interacted with before,
you don't have this intuition.
So what happens in the
context of a sprint?
All of this gets amplified.
In a sprint, you're time-boxed,
so you're doing things really
fast.
It's a high pressure situation.
It's not just you,
but probably you
and a bunch of sprinters who
are all in the same boat as you.
You don't understand
your user really well.
So Burgan and I are often
placed in situations like this
because we both work
on products where
we are distant from our users.
We don't understand our
users very well, that often.
So what happens?
You've seen that in
sprints like this,
there is analysis paralysis
because your sprinters are not
confident about deciding how to
move forward with your design.
You end up making safe choices.
So your design solutions
are not strong.
Sprint outcomes suffer.
You just don't see that
big leap that you want
to see at the end of a sprint.
So we need to help you and
your sprinters build intuition.
How do we do this?
So we think immersion is a
great solution to doing this.
Good design in sprints
is about making
educated and informed
decisions about how
to solve a problem that
your users are facing.
So with immersion,
you're helping
your sprinters
gain the foundation
to confidently design solutions.
So let's bring it all together.
Immersive sprints create
a realistic environment
to guide your sprinters,
drive great outcomes,
and then validate
sprint outcomes.
If you don't understand
your users really well
and you want to design
solutions for them
in a fast-paced
sprint environment,
then immersion is
a great technique
to set you up for success.
So how do we do this?
We are going to go over
a few techniques today.
First, we're going to talk
about doing pre- and post-sprint
research, so actually
incorporating research
as part of your sprint.
Then, creating immersion during
the design sprint itself.
Third, participate
redesign sprint.
So this is when you're
co-designing with their users.
You actually ask your users
to come to the sprint with you
and take part in
it as a sprinter.
And then last, instead of saving
validation for the last stage,
incorporate validation at
every stage of the sprint.
Make sure that you
check in with your users
at the end of each
day so that you
know you're on the right path.
So to give you an understanding
of how all of this
works in practice,
we're going to walk
through two case studies
of successful sprints
that Burgan and I have run.
So first, I'm going to
hand it off to Burgan
to talk about a really
interesting sprint she
ran in Kenya.
BURGAN SHEALY: All right.
I'm excited to tell you
guys about a sprint I ran
with an app called Afriscout.
Now, we were
kicking off this app
to help herders survive
ongoing drought.
Now, pastoralists are nomadic
or semi-nomadic people
who move their livestock
between pastures
depending on the season.
And now, with the emergence
of climate change,
rainfall patterns have
shifted, forcing herders
to find new routes,
new pastures,
and new sources of water.
And their traditional methods
of finding good grazing lands,
like word of mouth, scouting,
ancestral knowledge,
have proven insufficient
to maintain healthy herds
in this changing landscape.
An organization called
Project Concern International,
a nonprofit based in San
Diego and a Google.org grantee
created a program that relayed
satellite data to pastoralists
that showed current
vegetative conditions.
Now, this gave the pastoralists
critical intelligence
about where to move their herds.
The proof of concept
was highly successful.
We saw 50% reduction
in herd mortality,
and an 80% adoption rate
in the local populations
that it was tested with.
But the delivery system was
cumbersome and inefficient.
The maps were auto-emailed
to the PCI field
staff who would print
them out, deliver them
to district livestock officers
who would then pass them
on to the locals.
So this process was slow
and difficult to scale.
So our question was, would
it be possible for us
to cut out those middlemen
and simply deliver them maps
from the satellite
straight to smartphones?
As we planned the sprint,
we recognize the difficulty
in properly understanding
the cultural, societal,
and usage scenarios encountered
by populations so different
from ourselves.
But we knew that the
community, as experts
of their own experience, would
have the historical context
and the knowledge of
what was and wasn't
important to the community.
So rather than just
consult the community,
we decided to involve it.
Now, as designers
and developers,
we often create
products for people.
Co-design is the act of creating
with stakeholders and users,
ensuring that the people most
affected by the solutions
are part of the
development process.
And this is really based
on the idea and the belief
that all people are creative.
Now, the design sprint
gives us a framework
to put this into practice.
And through the
sprint process, we
can guide users through the
ideation and creation process
to really give voice
to their ideas.
As you can imagine, we had a
lot of different perspectives
around this challenge.
So we had to build
the right sprint team.
And we had quite a
large team with a number
of diverse stakeholders.
We had our geographic
information systems specialist,
who was our mapping specialist.
We had local developers
and a UX researcher
from iHub, which is a
incubation space and in Nairobi.
We had two staffers
from PCI in San Diego,
and we had UX
designers from Google.
But most importantly,
we had two pastoralists
from different
districts in Tanzania.
And then we had
three PCI field staff
from Ethiopia and Tanzania,
who worked directly
with the pastoralists
and had been
part of this proof
of concept program.
So it was important
to us that this app
transcended geographic
and tribal boundaries.
Now, this team required
the integration
of experts and users really
working closely together.
So empathy between our
participants was essential,
and face-to-face
communication was best.
So we all gathered in
iHub's office in Nairobi.
Now, co-creation can be applied
at any stage of the design
development process through
different activities.
And as we created
the schedule, we
thought deeply about
how to include our users
at each stage of this process.
And by incorporating
user feedback
throughout this process, we
can avoid the anchoring effect,
where we're going to really
see that human tendency
to rely on that first
piece of information
to make subsequent judgments.
So during the understand
phase, our users
helped us understand
the problems phase
through lightning talks,
and documenting and sharing
[INAUDIBLE] ways.
Now, you can see, some of
the topics that we discussed
were technical infrastructure,
offline experience,
battery life, traditional
decision-making,
so it was really
important to users
that these maps worked offline.
They were not always connected.
And traditional
decision-making was
something I don't think
we would have talked
about if we had run this
sprint in San Diego or here
in Mountain View.
It really is something that--
we learned the elders make
a lot of the decisions
around where to move the herds.
But the younger generation are
the one with the smartphone.
So we had to take those types
of things into consideration
as we considered the design.
So to make the
pastoralists' experience
resonate with all of
the sprint team members,
we broke into groups and
created user journey maps.
These were really
important, because people
are good at thinking
in terms of stories
about people and the
things that they do,
and what happens to them.
And stories can be useful
in generative design
to invoke empathy
and imagination,
and trigger ideas for
a more ideal future.
We used crazy eights
to allow the team
to generate a ton of different
ideas based on everything
we learned in the
understand phase.
And to help our users
with this activity,
we really gave some
structure to it
by giving them props
to sketch around.
So we did this in four phases.
And during the decide
phase, we really
gave our users more power in
the decision-making process
with extra votes, and we
reminded our other participants
to evaluate each
idea, considering
what our audience experienced
and what they wanted.
So depending on the level
of the fidelity that you're
aiming for, one of the
most difficult phases
to incorporate users in can
be the prototyping phase.
Paper prototypes might be
the most inclusive way.
And those are totally OK.
We were aiming for a
little bit higher fidelity.
And so we considered letting
our users go during this phase.
But they actually
wanted to stay.
And their participation
actually proved crucial.
When the designers were
designing this middle screen,
they were struggling to
come up with iconography
that would really represent
some of the diverse ideas
that we were trying
to get across.
This location has no water.
Or scary animals were
cited in this location.
Maybe you shouldn't
take your herd there.
But we were able
to rapidly iterate,
and show our designs
to the users,
and get immediate feedback, so
that we were able to confirm
which icons resonated
and which ones didn't.
So for use or testing, it was
important to solicit feedback
from a larger and
more diverse group
than was just the sprint team.
If you'll remember,
we had sprinters
from Ethiopia and Tanzania.
But we were in Kenya, so we
were able to go about an hour
south of Nairobi and
test our prototype
with a group of Maasai.
And this proved
extremely valuable,
as we saw the validity
of this tool immediately
and that the approach
we chose would
transcend geographic
and tribal boundaries.
Now, the spring process allowed
us to find common ground,
to share ideas, and
develop a common language
and work together
to fully understand
the user needs from the
very outset of the project.
Next, we're going to
talk about a case study
that Samir did here at Google.
SAMIR FALKE: Great.
What an impactful sprint.
So cool.
All right, so I'm going
to switch gears a bit,
and I'm going to talk about
the product that I work on,
and that's Google Station.
Now, just as a
recap, Google Station
is a product that's
bringing high quality public
Wi-Fi to next billion
user markets worldwide.
Now, a little bit of a caveat.
I can't really talk
about the actual product
that we were designing
in the sprint,
but I can talk
about the process.
And that's what I'm
going to do here.
So a while ago, someone in our
team had this really cool idea.
They wanted to bring
in the features that
are present in a
different Google product
into Google Station.
He got super excited.
We talked to this team, and
that team got super excited.
And we were all ready
to have this happen,
but we didn't know how.
So we didn't know what this
experience would look like.
A great reason to have a sprint.
We also had never worked
together as a team.
So there was no
working relationship.
Another great reason to have a
sprint, to bring teams together
so they can establish trust.
Now, here's another challenge.
The Google Station team is
based largely in Mountain View.
This other product
is based in Asia.
And at the time, the user
that we were designing for
was in India.
So three different countries.
Really challenging.
And going back to the slide
that Burgan showed earlier,
we had an answer, from
the business side,
how this product would work.
And we also knew that, from
an engineering standpoint,
we could most
likely make it work.
But what we didn't know
is, is this something
that our users even care about?
We didn't know if this was
desirable for our users.
So this big gap was something
we needed to address.
So we decided that we should
run an immersive sprint.
So the sprint challenge was
design an experience aligned
with user needs that would
combine functionality
of two products in
a very seamless way.
But before we could even
talk about seamless,
and the interaction
design, and all of that,
I really wanted
us to figure out,
does this make
sense for our users?
So I flexed the standard five
phase methodology of the sprint
and added an extra phase which
is that orange circle you
see here, for strategy.
We wanted to figure
out, is there
a strong user focused product
strategy for this product?
And this was critical.
We didn't know if this
would work for our users.
And this product
strategy needed to come
from actual user insights.
We didn't know our
user that well.
So we added two more
phases to the sprint.
Before the sprint,
we added research.
After the sprint,
Different kinds of
research, though.
Before the sprint, we added
foundational research.
And after the
sprint, we were going
to validate the design
solutions we had come up with,
with research to validate it.
So that was also in
the field, but it was
a different style of research.
Now, this extended the
duration of the sprint.
And we invited all of
our sprint participants
to actually take
part in the research.
We thought this was
really important
because that would be an
immersive experience for them.
And it would lay the
foundation for them
to effectively
participate in the sprint
and come up with great
design solutions.
So this was also a lot of
overhead in terms of planning,
because that meant
travel, going out
into the field
for a large group.
So to recap, understand
the user context
doing foundational research.
Use those user insights to
drive the entire sprint.
And then, when you have
design solutions as outcomes,
take them back into the field to
validate them with your users.
So that was the process
that we followed.
So how did we do this research?
For both the pre- and
post-sprint research,
we use a technique
known as intercepts.
Now, by intercepts I mean
going out into the field,
finding a user,
asking them if they
can spend a few
minutes with you,
and then doing an interview.
And you can do an
interview and ask them
about their habits,
and their lives,
and you get a lot of
foundational information
about them.
Or you can show
them a prototype.
And this could be a
clickable prototype,
it could be a live
product, it could be
sketches on a piece of paper.
And you can ask them to use this
prototype to do certain tasks
and observe how they do it.
And this would be evaluative.
So intercepts are really
flexible in that sense.
You could use them for
different styles of research.
And it's also in a user's
natural environment.
So instead of
bringing a user to you
and asking them
to come to a lab,
you're going out to a user.
So you're putting them at ease.
And paper prototypes
are totally OK.
So one of the things I
really love about intercepts
is that they're really scrappy.
You can put them together
in a really short time.
And also, they're
cross-functional.
This gives your team, your
non-user experience research
and design team, your
VMs, your engineers,
to take part in research
and actually come face
to face with their users.
It's amazing and
eye-opening for them.
This is why I love intercepts.
So that was the research part.
Now, let's talk about
that strategy piece.
To figure out if we had a right
user-focused product strategy,
we used a technique known
as value prop canvas.
So based on those
user insights, we
asked users who were already
using Google Station.
We made a list of all the
features in that product
and what the pinpoints
of users were,
using Google Station then.
So we had all the user pains.
Then, we made a list
of all of the gains
that users are seeing
by using that product.
So we knew the user gains.
And then we went to the sprint.
We went through a
lot of sketching,
we diverged, we voted
on ideas, we converged.
We came out with
a few solutions.
We did the same with
those solutions.
Are any of the features
in the solution
going to relieve the pains
that users are facing?
Are they going to boost the
gains that users are seeing?
If both of these boxes map, then
you know what you're designing
is great for your users.
If they don't map, then
you have a problem.
You don't have a strong
value proposition.
And that's when you have to
decide whether this even makes
sense to move forward with.
So this is what we used for
exploring product strategy.
So what did I learn
by running the sprint?
First, the sequence of methods
that you use in a sprint
really matters.
And if I hadn't taken
the time to think
about the sprint challenge and
add a product strategy piece,
we wouldn't have
been successful.
So think about the
sequence of products.
Do a dry run.
Try to see if one method
feeds into the other.
Does the output
of one method feed
into the input of the other?
If there is a gap,
then address it.
Make stakeholders your partners.
Especially when you're running
a broad sprint like this,
you want them to
be your partners.
You want them to agree
with you, invest the time,
and money, and resources.
And you want to do daily
check-ins with them.
Tell them how you're doing.
What did you do today?
What did you achieve as a team?
Get feedback.
Work on it.
I've never run a sprint that has
always gone according to plan.
So things go wrong,
people have questions,
they question the very
premise of your sprint,
things take too long to run,
methods don't go as you plan,
logistical issues.
So be nimble.
Be agile.
Be prepared to change
things around on the fly.
One of the great side
benefits of the sprint
is that you're bringing
two teams together
who have not worked
together, and you're
going to drive a lot of
alignment between them,
and really strong working
relationship between them.
So no matter what happens,
you're going to get that.
And we got that.
And then the last thing
I wanted to leave you
at for this case
study is that this
was a super successful
sprint for us,
not because we figured out this
amazing new product that we
wanted to launch.
We actually learned that we
did not have a strong value
proposition with this new idea.
This did not make
sense for our users.
At the end of the
sprint we decided
we didn't want to move
forward with this.
So the fact that
the sprint helped
us understand very quickly if
the time, effort, and resources
required to build
this was worth it,
makes it super powerful for us.
So you might be thinking,
I'm not going to Kenya.
And I'm not going to India.
Why does any of
this matter to me?
Well, have you ever designed
for users in regions
different from where you live?
I bet you have.
Have you ever designed
or developed solutions
for users who are
different from you?
Kids, the elderly,
minorities, people who
are less tech savvy than you?
I bet you have.
And have you designed for use
cases you aren't familiar with?
Have you made a product for
the automotive industry,
or made a fitness app and
you've never been to the gym?
We do this all the time.
This is our job.
Immersive sprints are
perfect for these use cases.
And why they're powerful
is because you now
have the opportunity to bring
your team with you to learn.
Instead of doing
research in a silo
and bringing a
research report back,
you can take them with you.
This is where the power of
sprints really shines through.
They're cross-functional,
they're participatory,
and they're democratic.
So now I'm going to present some
tips to run your own immersive
sprints with Burgan.
So the very first one I went
over a little bit in advance.
This is intercepts.
Now, intercepts are a
great research methods.
They're very scrappy and fast.
They don't work well when you
need to recreate a lab setting.
So if you're doing an
internet of things set up
and you need hardware, you
want to recreate the home,
intercepts don't work well.
But if you have an app, if you
have paper prototypes, if you
want to do foundational
research and talk to users
and just learn about them,
intercepts are great.
Now, it's important
to know that if you
go in a large group of 10 people
trying to talk to one user,
you're going to scare them off.
So don't do that.
Try to split up
into smaller groups.
And then split up and talk
to people on your own,
come back, regroup,
and share your notes.
If you're doing
international research,
there's a couple of
things to be aware of.
Be aware of cultural nuances,
how to talk to people,
how to address them, dressing.
So do some research beforehand.
Get good interpreters
or translators,
because even if they speak
the same language as you,
there might be important
nuances that you would miss.
If it's possible, and if
your user is OK with it,
ask them beforehand if
you can take a video.
If they say yes, take a video
of your interaction with them.
Because when you take a
video back to your team,
it is super powerful, way more
powerful than a research report
can be.
Paper prototypes and focus
groups are OK for this.
Because you're talking
to so many users,
you'll correct for that.
And then watch out
for selection bias.
We have an idea in our
head of who our user is.
So there is a bias
to go and talk
to users that you think would
be likely users of your app.
Don't do that.
You're outside in the field.
You have access to a
diverse range of users.
So go talk to everyone.
And then one last tip.
We try to make
sure that we don't
prime our users to give
us answers that they
think we want to hear.
So we try not to tell them
that, hey I designed this.
Give me your feedback.
Because they'll be nice to
you and they'll tell you,
this is amazing, even
if they don't like it.
So we try to save
that information
for after the interview.
BURGAN SHEALY: Those
are some great tips.
And a lot of them will
apply to co-design as well.
Now, co-design is a
fundamental change
in the relationship between
product creators and users.
Traditionally, experts have
gone out and observed, done
interviews, with
mostly passive users.
In co-design, users are deeply
involved in the ideation
and creation process.
So you really want to prepare
your users in advance.
Let them know what to
expect in the design sprint,
talk about the
different activities
that they might go
through, and help
them reflect on
their experiences
that they normally
perceive as routine.
So perhaps you ask them to do a
diary study beforehand, or have
them talk to other
members of their community
to get a wider perspective.
Logistics are also
quite important.
You're going to want to
allow more time for each
of the activities and more
time to explain them as well.
Do you need a translator?
Similar to intercepts,
it might be useful.
Are you in the natural
context of the experience?
Or are you asking the users
to come into your space?
What would make them
more comfortable?
What materials do you
need to allow your users
to fully express themselves
and to take their ideas down?
Are they comfortable
with drawing?
Would they be more
comfortable if you gave them
something to build with,
different components
that they could put together?
Would they be interested in
role-playing or storytelling?
So really think through
all of the contingencies
and the schedule of your sprint.
Now, facilitation is
going to be key here,
and you're going to be
switching roles a little bit
from translator of
the user experience,
to facilitating the
users, and guiding them
through the creative process.
And finally, make sure you
include a diverse and inclusive
user set.
And why do we do this?
This sounds like a lot of work.
So what are the
benefits of co-design?
You're really going to
get an increased knowledge
and empathy for the
user for the full team.
And that's key.
You're going to have all
your engineers, your PMs,
face-to-face with the users.
You're going to build better
and more innovative ideas.
You're going to have
lots and lots of--
more and better ideas.
Your decision-making is
going to be more efficient,
and your sprint
participants are going
to be more confident in the
decisions that they make.
And you're going to have
immediate validation
of concepts and ideas, just as
I discussed with the iconography
in our app for Afriscout.
We were able to immediately
validate what worked and what
didn't.
And you'll be able to establish
a deeper and long term
relationship with your users.
Now, what if you can't bring
users in for the full sprint?
Maybe they have to work.
They're not able to
take that much time off
to come in and participate
in your sprint.
We also often do something
called extended user
participation.
So this is an alternative
where we bring users
in at key milestones
within the sprint.
So we'll recruit
users to do check-ins
at critical milestones or
at the end of each phase.
We'll do cognitive walkthroughs.
We'll let them look at sketches.
We'll just show them what
we've been working on
and get their feedback.
You might have to pivot,
but you'll want to plan time
to act on the feedback
that they give you.
Now, what if you just can't
bring your users to you at all
and you can't go to them?
What do we do then?
SAMIR FALKE: So that's when
remote sprinting comes in.
And we'll be honest with you.
This has not been
very successful
and we don't highly
recommend it.
But sometimes it's unavoidable.
Your users are far away,
you can't go to them.
So you can use things
like slides or docs
to collaborate remotely.
You can use Google Forms
and send out a survey,
and get your users to take
a survey to get insights.
One of the things
that we've done,
especially when you're doing
research from many time zones
away, is overnight research.
So an example was we
were doing a sprint here
for a product that was
based in Indonesia.
So we did a lot of work
all day, packaged it up,
sent it over there.
Researcher ran research
for us overnight,
and we had feedback waiting
for us the next morning.
So that was great.
Obviously, this is very
situation specific.
So if you can't do
this, you might want
to consider taking a break.
And instead of doing all five
days of the sprint in one go,
do two days at a time.
Break off, do some research,
come back, and then
regroup the next week.
So these are some techniques
for doing remote sprinting.
So to recap, we talked
about intercepts.
We talked about co-design.
We talked about extended
user participation
and remote sprinting.
With that, we hope
that we've shown
you the value of
immersive design sprints
and given you the
right tools to run
your own successful
immersive sprint.
Now, we'd love to hear from you.
So please provide feedback
for this session by signing
in on google.com/io/schedule.
And if you want more helpful
resources about design sprints,
go to
designsprintkit.withgoogle.com.
That's it from us.
Thank you.
BURGAN SHEALY: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]